I can feel myself being dragged down
into into a morass of of this rap
hip-hop lifestyle and uh the other night
my family had to sit me down for an
intervention and they had to tell me
that it was time to it might be time to
move on and so it might be like a
supernova shining bright in the sky for
just a moment and we all remember Finly
that moment in time you we we think what
might have been but yeah I I I I don't
know I don't know if there's a path
forward
here
let's look at the stats I've got the
facts my money like lizard my pockets
are fat homie I'm epic don't be a wh dog
it's a y homie no cap look at the graphs
look at my charts you're blowing money
on strippers and cars you going to
prison I'm on television dog no one
knows who you are keep hating on me on
the internet my comment section all W
car and I make racks off compound
interest y'all live with your parents
Niki take some notes I just did this for
fun all my people download this let's
get a billboard number one all right b
Diddy can I call you b Diddy does that
even make sense in the rap World B for
Benjamin I don't know what Diddy means
but B shapir what do we what you know do
you have a rap name it's it's Dr
drel um we just played a little bit of
your number one rap song and uh I think
if I had gone back 10 years to my garage
and been sitting there with you going
who is this fast talking crazy
right-wing Maniac if you would have told
me 10 years later he'd be the number one
rapper in America well I guess relative
to everything else going on in the world
it makes a lot of sense fishizzle
fishizzle I mean so you know when we
were sitting there as homies talking
over our lives that things have gone in
weird directions over the past decade
that portal that opened the alternative
reality yeah it has not yet closed and
we we are there so if you've become a
rapper now where does this put you 10
years from
now
SCA I don't know
I don't know man I mean maybe maybe I'll
take up your dream of playing in the NBA
because yeah as Kevin Garnett once said
anything is
possible I'm glad to see your skill set
developing Ben but let's uh let's mostly
talk about life and the state of the
world and politics and and all of that
stuff well I guess is there anything
else you want to say about the rap
situation you did it you're number one
it's very exciting but you're moving on
you're not going to it's the it it's the
greatest cultural troll of all time I
mean I'm just going I'm just going to
Pat ourselves on the back over here
there there has never been a cultural
troll as good as this I mean I'm sorry
but but me becoming a number one hip-hop
artist is
legitimately like all credit to Tom all
credit to to Nova his girlfriend who
directed and produced it all credit to
my parents who paid for 15 years of
classical violin lesson so I could
become a number one hip-hop star
eventually it it was it's it's been it's
been a journey it's been a journey but
you know will this be my career going
forward I I I have doubts I don't know I
feel myself already drawn to the
lifestyle I spent the weekend clubbing
yeah as as as we as we Orthodox Jews do
I I was out at the I was out at the
clubs sipping the Henny I was going to
say is kavas is cavasier kosher I'm not
so sure or you put the kosher in
cavasier I I have no idea I have no idea
but you know I I can feel myself being
dragged down into into a morass of of
this rap hip-hop lifestyle and uh the
other night my family had to sit me down
for an intervention and they had to tell
me that it was time to it it might be
time to move on and so it might be like
a supernova shining bright in the sky
for just a moment and we all remember
fondly that moment in time yeah we we
think what might have been but yeah I I
I I don't know I don't know if there's a
path forward here joking aside for just
a moment because uh Andrew Breitbart
always said that politics is Downstream
from culture and definitely you have now
hit into this C well you've been in the
cultural thing for a long time uh but
like this particular rap thing like has
hit in a different way what does that
say about the state of the culture like
like actually joking aside that this is
kind of where we're at where this sort
of thing happens I mean joking aside
it's the saddest thing in the entire
world I mean joking aside the fact that
you know you and I we we spend our life
on politics and that the subset of
Americans who follow politics might be
10 million people total like follow it
at a granular relatively close level
yeah that might be 10 million people and
in four days we have 10 million views on
this YouTube video and probably it's
been seen at this point on various
Outlets by 100 million people I mean
it's the number one charting song in the
world on iTunes and the fact that pop
culture is so just dominant in terms of
what people actually watch and imbibe
and that's an uphill battle for those of
us who actually care about values and
principles because the culture that we
used to be steeped in which used to be
things like synagogue and church has
been completely taken over by the pop
culture which is why now you're seeing
all these dumb fights over Taylor Swift
and Travis Kelce and whether it's a CIA
op and all this kind of dumb
nonsense how are you feeling about the
state of the world I think last we spoke
was probably two or three weeks right
after October 7th obviously the war is
still going on hostage is still there
everything else I mean we're not only
related to that but just the sort of
General State of where everything's out
before we get into some of the granular
stuff I mean you and I before we got on
there we said how are you doing and you
said doing fine everything is terrible
and uh that that that seems to be a
pretty good synopsis of where things are
right we have an unprecedent
unprecedented crisis on our Southern
border we have continued militants by
Iran in the Middle East we by the Biden
Administration we have a breakdown of
the social Fabric in the United States
on everything from drugs to Crime we we
have a stagnant economy like it just
things seem pretty bad out there and and
the great hope that that is remains sort
of rebuilding at the local level but
again the the cultural forces in favor
of sort of top- down dictation are are
very very strong so it's it's definitely
a rough time which is amazing because if
you had asked me four years ago where we
were like 2019 before Co before BLM
riots before the election before any of
that stuff I say that we were in as
about as good a position as I can
remember America and the West ever
having been in during my lifetime and
how fastly how how fast things can
change it's pretty amazing yeah is that
a uh would you give that credit right
there to Trump and is that even though I
know a few days before disantis dropped
out you actually said that if you were
voting at this moment you would have
voted for disantis but I think you've
been pretty fair to both of them and you
did vote for Trump last time I'm 99%
sure right yes I does that sort of expl
the the Resurgence of trump right there
that it was pretty decent people do
remember that and then if you just
remove the co thing it's like look look
what happened here yeah I mean and that
that's the smart race if he runs that
race if he runs the race and he just
says remember 2019 and then he just
points at Joe Biden then that's a very
winable race for him I mean right now
he's in the strongest polling position
for any Republican Contender since
George W Bush in 2004 so you know he he
certainly has you know a a serious shot
at at reelection possibility here and
that's because Joe Biden has governed in
truly awful ways and it does demonstrate
that again voting has consequences when
you elect a president who has principles
that do not serve the American people
then what you end up with is a world on
fire and that that's what I think a lot
of people are feeling like right now
they feel like Joe Biden is is a person
who is not on fire but the world is on
fire Donald Trump is a person who's on
fire but the world is not on fire and so
if you have that choice I'd prefer to
have the guy who tweets crazy stuff but
also the world is is in a pretty good
playe what what do you think could be
worse right now like what could be
screwing up more you know what I mean
like I get it like we could be in World
War III right now but we might be in a
couple weeks I mean it just seems to me
that we have a man with dementia who's
clearly not the pilot of this plane we
don't really know who the pilot of plane
is nobody thinks he's competent and yet
here we are and all of the issues that
you just laid out from the border to
International stuff to biomics and
everything else I mean I I think that
what could theoretically get worse on
the foreign policy front there are two
things uh that that could get worse or
really three uh one obviously is that
the the UND dropped shoe here is China
and Taiwan I think there's every
possibility that if Donald Trump is
leading significantly in the polls come
June July that China just goes for it
that China says okay we're going to
blockade Taiwan because good shot that
Trump is President anyway we got to get
get our liix in while Joe Biden is
President and if it sinks his reelect
campaign well he's probably going to
lose anyways there's no reason for us to
to wait on this thing until Trump is
President so that is a shuee that could
easily drop sometime this summer that's
sort of my out of the boox pick for for
terrible things that can happen in in
terms of the Middle East yeah again I
think that you're going to continue to
see low-level War I think that Israel is
going to have to turn up north and hit
Hezbollah that's just something Israel
is going to have to do to maintain its
own security and then the question is
how far Iran wants to get drawn into
that war the the biggest danger there is
that if the United States shows a lot of
daylight between itself and Israel then
you could see Iran start to really up
the ante with regard to backing hisbah
in some sort of War there and then you
could see things really start to
metastasize and spin out of control
America's deterent power in the Middle
East has been the thing that has kept
the situation at least somewhat
contained to this point even that
because Biden doesn't have any real
deterrent power or or any sort of
principled strength even that deterrence
has been failing in kind of soft ways
but it could fail much worse the
deterrence could fail significantly
significantly more and then obviously
when it comes to the situation in
Ukraine you could see serious
Battlefield reversals against Ukraine if
Trends hold if the Russians pourn
another round of Manpower if the
Europeans and the Americans decide that
there's no deal to be had there again I
think that nobody has an interest in the
continuation of the war with with the
lines Frozen as they are the only
question is whether there's actually a
deal on the table and Biden has not been
transparent about what exactly his aims
are with regard to Ukraine so those are
all the things that can happen in terms
of foreign policy a short list there and
then in terms of domestic policy
obviously you could see a wide variety
of things happen in domestic policy you
could theoretically see a terror attack
from somebody cross the southern border
which would completely shift the lines
when it comes to American politics you
you you could see a fullscale economic
down downt which we've avoided thus far
but theoretically could happen I mean
we've had unexpected downturns before in
fact nearly every downturn in my
lifetime has been quote unquote
unexpected we we could certainly see
some sort of catalyzing event that is
driven by the media into 2020 like riots
that sort of stuff feels always like
it's 5 seconds away from breaking out
that if the media decides to whip
everybody into a frenzy before the
election that could be a serious problem
and and you could obviously see the
federal government crack down on freedom
of speech the way that they did in 2020
but much more significantly so again as
bad as they say that um you know the it
always gets darkest just before it goes
pitch black and uh and so that and so
that may be where we are on the other
hand maybe this is the maybe maybe we've
hit the bottom maybe we're going to have
a bounce here if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
screaming check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell